bienvenue pour ce nouveau journal de la
rédaction nous sommes le vendredi 20
février et dans l'actualité locale la
compétition internationale de cyclisme
sur piste au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines d'hier le
français installé à montigny le
bretonneux a brillé en ajoutant un
nouveau titre à son palmarès nous
parlerons également des chances des
tricolores pour le week end la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines réfléchit
actuellement à son budget pour son
président la situation est inédite et
particulièrement délicate va falloir
réaliser plusieurs millions d'économies
et puis comme chaque fin de semaine
comme chaque vendredi nous reviendrons
sur l'essentiel de l'actualité depuis
lundi la campagne pour l'élection
départementale qui s'accélère pervis le
magnifique c'était la une de l'équipe en
ce vendredi matin le français réalise un
nouvel exploit lors des mondiaux de
cyclisme nous irons dans l'enceinte du
vélodrome dans un instant au duplexe
retrouver à michael almy d'euros et
notre consultant indien du jarlier pour
écouter leurs réactions évoquer la suite
de la compétition qui se terminera
dimanche mais tout d'abord les images et
le résumé de cette épreuve est dite du
keirin c'était hier à saint quentin en
yvelines au vélodrome nationale regarder
il la fellini montrent un françois
pervis a conservé son titre de champion
du monde du keirin ce jeudi sur la piste
du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines devant un
public totalement acquis à sa cause et
qui l'a poussé tout au long de l'épreuve
le pistard tricolore de 30 ans s'est
très facilement imposé en dominant le
néo zélandais et eduardo keynes et le
malaisien awang sous là est vraiment
beau parce que je vous dis par rapport à
steve r j'étais vraiment au fond du trou
je reviens vraiment très loin et le
faire comme ça à domicile devant sa
famille mon fan club mes amis mes
partenaires c'est un sentiment différent
est vraiment dans ma mémoire ça c'est
sûr lui c'est clair ça grand champion ça
c'est une évidence à deuxième titre de
champion du monde d'affilée
je crois que ça confirme son grand
charisme ses grandes compétences et sa
volonté toujours être au plus haut du
podium
françois est un sacré bonhomme un titre
particulier pour françois pervis qui
s'entraînent tous les jours sur la piste
du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et qui habite
montigny le bretonneux
c'est purement à domicile ce j'habite à
aller à 500 mètres à vol d'oiseau d'ici
oui c'est vraiment domicile je crois que
je suis seulement des équipes de france
à habiter dans la ville où se situe à
montigny-le-bretonneux dans la ville où
se situe le vélodrome après la victoire
de françois pervis ce jeudi soir le clan
français et totalise désormais deux
médailles d'or dans ces championnats du
monde sur piste de médaille d'or en deux
jours on se souhaite le meilleur jusqu'à
jusqu'à dimanche
on a des belles courses qui vont ceux
qui vont s'enchaîner c'est toute la
dynamique de l'équipe de france qui est
derrière ces deux belles médailles et ce
n'est sûrement pas terminé la collection
des tricolores pourrait s'étoffer une
nouvelle fois ce vendredi soir avec le
kilomètre et un certain françois pervis
et au vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux on retrouve en duplex à
présent pour la rédaction de tv film est
calme il devra assister à la technique
de mélanie poquet également de williams
elle vous êtes avec notre consultant une
belle performance une nouvelle fois pour
françois pervis c'est ça françois pervis
a vraiment écrasé la concurrence
donc hier soir vraiment une belle
performance une belle course indienne de
charrière mérite dans le dernier
allemand passe devant lui at on peut y
arriver il a déjà gagné puisque avec des
compressions dans la maîtrise vraiment
et on l'a vu par vous le sentiez vous on
était ensemble pour la course senti
vraiment lors du dernier virage vraiment
ça c'est parce que vous entendez bien
tous les deux mickaël peut-être passer
votre micro à ryan parce que visiblement
un petit sous cinq ans sur la qualité du
son d'accord
donc pour moi oui il avait gagné il
avait gagné à l'entamé du dernier du
dernier tour vraiment il n'y avait pas
de possibilité d éclatement dans la
gestion de son effort dans la gestion de
son des preuves
il maîtrisait maîtrisé son sujet et donc
le dtn était ravi également déjà deux
médailles en deux jours deux médailles
d'or en deux jours c'est fait partie des
objectifs de toute façon on est là pour
ils sont là pour cinq médailles par jour
bon maintenant voilà cinq médailles d'or
ben pourquoi pas moi je pense qu'on fera
plus on verra on verra dimanche entière
allait pour qu'ils ont là un petit mot
également donc sur les épreuves de ce
soir de ce week-end plus tôt il ya
vraiment des chances de médailles or
alors ce week-end on a la vitesse paraît
la vitesse individuelle avec francs
françois pervis bien sûr grégory baugé
et michael d'almeida quentin lafargue
on va voir 4,4 vrais concurrents qui
sont là pour aller chercher des podiums
et puis il ya aussi le keirin pas mal
oui le karine féminin il va y avoir les
preuves de dominium féminine l'omnium
masculin qui vient juste de débuter
aussi qui se terminera demain voilà
beaucoup de chance avec des concurrents
français qui est on allé chercher des
fonds et c'est d'aller chercher des
podiums
thomas boudât sur sur l'omnium c'est
c'est un favori
il est champion du monde en titre il
vient juste de finir la première épreuve
le scratch et il aime faire 7e on verra
on verra encore ce soir il ya encore des
îles vanille et placez y est parce que
balogou oms et ça c'est une fois dans le
fait régulièrement sans laisser des
chambres d'hôtes est il et il est en
forme comme qui le présente en france et
poussé par le public et il n'y a pas de
maintenant il faut attendre que les
épreuves se déroulent et puis le
résultat sera là demain et à françois
pervis aussi ce soir également une
médaille
le kilomètre ce soir ils étaient toutes
là s'en tenant du titre comme tuant les
trois épreuves sur itunes s'aligne sur
ces championnats a dit sûr que ce soir
il est le grand favori va partir en
dernière position
je bats on va voir et on va tous être
derrière lui pour le pousser à aller
chercher un deuxième titre mondial
et encore je me met à l'aise avec tous
les doutes français qui va la journée
avec nous et les filles aussi pour
l'instant les déçoit légèrement
est-ce que vous pensez que ça peut ça
peut se débloquer ce week-end alors on a
un thomas de 200 mètres la tour de
vitesse film qui a commencé à l'insp à
tout à l'heure
le tournoi est très près dans ce sens
virginie cueff et 10e temps et elle est
à trois dixièmes de là du meilleur temps
donc charles 200 mètres c'est rien c'est
vraiment très très serré il va falloir
être très fort tactiquement
et puis elles ont l'avantagé de
connaître la piste par coeur
pour l'instant on n'a pas eu des preuves
vous justement toutes ces tactiques et
la smeda piste avait son importance
lâchant la vitesse individuelle des
filles vont peut-être avoir ce petit ce
petit plus du fait de courir domicile
est juste de connaître la piste pas
seulement d'avoir pu lui qui va les
booster et de connaître comment vos
principales vraiment très très bien at
least un petit mot sur 110 clair
également elle connaît pour l'instant
des championnats du monde difficile
alors quand on s'en doutait un peu moins
110 malheureusement ça qu'elle avait
fait une très belle très dernière coupe
du monde avec une quatrième place en
vitesse là le temps n'est pas du tout du
tout dans ne doit elle pas du tout dans
le coup au niveau du temps maintenant
ben les matches un contre un c'est un
autre c'est à nous discipline on est sur
des combats de boxe
et là c'est la tête qui est c'est la
tête qui prend qui prend le qui prend le
jeu comme toujours le public du
vélodrome répond présent il ya encore
cinq mille spectateurs aujourd'hui il y
à vraiment ça a poussé françois pervis
pour pour la médaille d'or vraiment un
sentiment dernier tour en tout cas
qu'ils dépensaient c'est un public ultra
chauvin de tasseaux dès qu'on a un
français en piste sa sacrée dans tous
les sens et c'est génial ça met tout le
temps tout en les poils on a vraiment la
chair de colombie avec joey belladonna
pour ça aussi pour les pour les
supporter c'est aussi génial vraiment
bravo bravo public de 50 à kim ne
connais pas encore je te promets de
donner des informations aux gens mais
voilà c'est que du bonheur merci à tous
les deux merci messieurs merci michael
vont rester au vélodrome bien évidemment
avec mélanie poker williams l on va vous
retrouver lundi pour en résumé le
complètent cette fin de compétition
merci également à yann qui nous
éclairent depuis le début de ce rendez
vous et pas seulement de du vélodrome
les gens qui viennent vous voir vous
êtes aussi les la lumière pour les
téléspectateurs de téléfilm merci à vous
merci à tous les deux le monde entier a
les yeux rivés sur le vélodrome et les
personnalités s'y pressent l'on pouvait
notamment croisé hier michel drucker des
ministres également ce jeudi patrick
kanner ministre de la ville de la
jeunesse et des sports était présent
pour apporter son soutien on les écoute
moi qui porte à l'éventuelle candidature
des jeux olympiques pour paris un des
éléments du dossier c'est 50 et en
yvelines ce stade vélodrome la piste de
bmx mais aussi
le golf qui est pas très loin donc on a
là un enjeu majeur et donc quand je vois
l'excellence de l'accueil du public et
cette grande compétition je me dis que
c'est un élément majeur de notre dossier
très beaux lots drôme le togo de france
et c'est un lillois qui le dit alors que
j'ai un beau stade vélodrome sur roues
vais vous le savez non vraiment là on a
un outil qui est formidable aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que les athlètes et
leurs entraîneurs sont vraiment dans
d'excellentes conditions d'accueil on va
à présent revenir sur les autres
performances des français dès le premier
jour l'équipe de france a remporté le
titre de vitesse nous étions bien
évidemment présent le reportage
le clan français a réussi ses débuts
dans ces championnats du monde sur la
piste du vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
grégory baugé kévin sireau et michael
d'almeida sont montés sur la plus haute
marche du podium dans l'épreuve de
vitesse par équipes une médaille
inespérée pour les tricolores
la nouvelle-zélande avait remporté cette
finale avec 3 dixièmes d'avancé sur les
français avant d'être disqualifié pour
passage de relais hors zone
conséquence les bleus sont en ordre ça
fait depuis 2011 qu'on va aller le
chercher ce titre en temps au tour et
l'a2 surcroît être à la maison avec un
public comme il y avait c'était vraiment
satisfaisant j'avais couru en 2006 aussi
où il y avait le même ambiance à
bordeaux et l'as d'être à la maison sur
notre petit entraînement de tous les
jours et de voir ce public est de monter
sa première marche et émouvant quoi
c'est pas une fin en soi mais presque
donc voilà on va pas bouder notre
plaisir aujourd'hui on est champion du
monde et meilleur on a on associe
boubaiou sur nos épaules pour en
profiter à la sortie du podium les fonds
sans saluer la performance de leurs
adversaires du jour
on est très satisfait on a quand même
franchi la ligne en deuxième pour pas
l'oublier il ya eu une erreur technique
de nos adversaires est ce que c'est ce
qui leur a permis de faire le meilleur
temps on sait pas on n'est pas là pour
en discuter
ça fait donc un plusieurs années qu'ils
sont aussi sur les podiums mais
il était champion du monde en titre
l'année passée qu'une équipe forte aussi
montante et je pense que maintenant ça
va être une équipe qui va aussi côtoyé
les les places sur les jeux donc affaire
à faire attention à bien se préparer
une médaille et des espoirs pour
l'avenir les sprinteurs français sont
désormais considérés comme les favoris
pour un podium aux jeux olympiques de
rio en 2016
on pense à rio depuis depuis bien
longtemps depuis vous savez depuis
depuis notre finale aux jeux olympiques
à londres
on pense déjà à are you on a vu ce qui
nous a manqué nous on est sans arrêt
dans la recherche pour rattraper ce qui
nous a manqué aujourd'hui on est
champion du monde c'est bien c'est beau
mais on va pas on va pas s'enflammer
c'est pas ce n'est pas une fin en soi il
faut pas que ça soit par là dessus il
n'y a rien d'acquis et champion du monde
c'est pour être champion olympique c'est
pour la même chose avant de penser aux
jeux de rio et aux médailles olympiques
les sprinteurs tricolores veulent
savourer leur titre
la france est une habituée de cette
distinction les bleus ont remporté ce
mercredi soir leur onzième titre en
vitesse par équipes depuis 1995 un
record et cette compétition de cyclisme
sur piste que tv fils vous fait vivre au
plus près en allant notamment à la
rencontre des plus petites équipes là
aussi le reportage est signée michael et
demi d'euros et william l c'est l'une
des plus petites délégations de ces
championnats du monde sur piste les
trois sud africain eugène soula
meyrinois nole démarrage kamaté sont
arrivés ce mardi au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines championne
d'afrique en titre l'équipe dispose
pourtant d'un budget réduit
la fédération sud africaine a seulement
payé les billets d'avion de la
délégation le staff est lui composé
d'une seule personne
ben moi ma fonction c'est je fais tout
je fais le mécanicien le coach sur la
piste le manager avec quelques petits
mots pour réconforter mettre les couvre
les coureurs en confiance je m'occupe de
toute la logistique
donc voilà c'est beaucoup beaucoup de
travail
il faut s'investir au niveau du matériel
et sud africain dispose également du
strict minimum au niveau du matériel
on est limité je me suis fait prêter du
matériel par la société une société du
coin d'ailleurs les coureurs ont un vélo
chacun donc ya pas de vélo de rechange
donc qu'est ce qui se passe et pendant
la compétition pendant qu'un coureur
cours comme il n'a pas vu l'ombre chance
je suis obligé d'adapter rapidement un
vélo d'un coureur qui courent pas pour
avoir un vélo de secours en cas de en
cas de chute ou en cas de crevaison
aucun incident contrairement aux autres
nations les trois sportifs sud africain
ne dorment pas à l'hôtel mais chez
l'habitant
le team manager aux francos canela
trouver un logement à trappes pour
réaliser des économies leurs hôtes à
réaménager la pièce en poussant les
meubles et en installant des matelas sur
le sol il les accueille gracieusement
voilà les circonstances ont fait que moi
je pouvait accueillir particulièrement
cette période-là et
moi si ça leur convenait parce que moi
là c'est pas non plus un hôtel quatre
étoiles ou 5 étoiles en mieux dans
l'esprit
voilà si ça leur convenait c'était
parfait par mois c'est ça leur va très
bien et moi c'est cool ça me permet de
discuter un peu avec eux d'échanger un
peu la culture de la culture du vélo qui
est un peu différente chez eux puis la
discipline aussi c'est incroyable de
rester ici avec philippe et de découvrir
la façon de vivre à la française et de
voir ça c'est un véritable trésor
les sud africains ne sont pas venus en
touristes sur cette compétition et
qu'ils espèrent réaliser quelques
records nationaux leur meilleure chance
la coureuse de 26 ans maresches kamaté
regard des hommes but est de réaliser
les performances sur la poursuite
individuelle et de battre le record de
l'afrique du sud
c'est un record qui date de 15 ans je
suis également engagé dans le scratch
j'espère obtenir une bonne place et si
mes jambes vont permettre une fois la
compétition terminée le dimanche 22
février les sud-africains préparons dans
la foulée leurs valises
le départ pour johannesburg et déjà
programmée pour le lundi matin
pas question de faire du tourisme
objectif réaliser nouvelle fois des
économies
depuis le début de cette compétition le
vélodrome fait le plein en terme de
spectateurs plus de 5000 personnes
présentes dans les tribunes
quotidiennement on retrouve aussi des
anciennes gloires du cyclisme qui sont
venus rencontrer les différents
champions le public a donc pu apercevoir
arnaud tournant c'est une légende de la
piste recordman de titres sur les
championnats du monde avec pas moins de
14 médailles d'or
nous sommes avec arnaud tournant
multiple médaillé aux championnats du
monde
alors c'était important pour vous d'être
ici aujourd'hui
oui c'était c'était important parce que
on est on est sur l'épreuve ultime à à
part les jeux olympiques c'est vrai que
les championnats du monde sont toujours
un événement majeur cette année on a la
chance de voir ces championnats en
france sur ce nouvel écrin de 50 ans
divina un super de vélodrome qu'on peut
sur lequel les français peuvent être
fiers de rouler
donc c'est vrai que c'est un événement
particulier et je me devais d'être parmi
parmi tous ceux qui vont côtoyer cette
fête est justement vous le regrettez pas
de ne pas avoir justement rouler sur
cette piste du vélodrome
non j'aurais peut-être l'occasion voilà
sur mes heures perdues j'en ai pas
beaucoup en ce moment mais c'est vrai
que
c'est quand il faudrait que je me penche
sur la question et me rapprocher des des
gestionnaires du site pour pour avoir la
chance de fouler ses quelques lattes de
bois et vous leur apportez un petit peu
votre expérience
non je pense je pense qu'ils en ont
assez ça fait des années et des années
qui sont au plus haut niveau
je leur ai apporté mon expérience quand
j'étais avec eux encore sur le vélo on a
on s'est côtoyé plusieurs années je
pense qu'aujourd'hui sont assez grands
assez mature est assez professionnel
pour justement donner le meilleur
d'eux-mêmes et convoité 7,7 plus belles
places qui est le titre de champion du
monde et vous êtes leur korman dans
l'épreuve des championnats du monde
by par et oui il paraît que
donc ça c'est une pression qu'on
pourrait qu'on peut émettre sur les
cours en français c'est à dire aller
déloger l'ancien merci beaucoup
harmattan nous refermons en présence est
large page dédiée aux mondiaux du
cyclisme rendez-vous donc lundi pour le
7-8 sport spécial dès 18h30 en direct
comme chaque vendredi dans le journal
retour sur l'essentiel de l'actualité et
on commence avec le vote du budget de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines il est prévu le 9 avril
prochain les conseillers communautaires
se sont d'ores et déjà réunis pour
discuter autour du débat d'orientation
budgétaire au coeur de ces discussions
la baisse des dotations 11 millions
d'euros prévus sur trois ans à un vrai
casse tête a reconnu l'exécutif comme
nous l'expliquent 4 nuls attend le
désengagement de l'état est très
important nous n'avons jamais vu cela
les mots ne sont pas rassurants ce jeudi
soir le président de l'agglomération
michel auger a décrit une situation
complexe un casse-tête pour l'exécutif
qui prépare son budget pour l'année
les chiffres sont là les dotation
d'intercommunalité seront en diminution
entre 2015 et 2017 de 3,7 millions
d'euros par an soit sur trois ans 11
millions de moins dans les caisses de la
casse qui a ajouté à cela pour cette
année une baisse également de la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
en résumé rien que pour 2015 ce sont 4,7
millions d'euros de perte nette pour les
finances de l'agglomération
il va falloir réduire la voilure a
prévenu l'exécutif qui a promis qu'il
n'y aurait pas d'augmentation d'impôts
mais cette voilure quelle est elle
l'agglomération a lancé trois audits
dont les conclusions ne sont pas encore
connus revoir certaines compétences et
se recentrer sur les principales
missions comme le développement
économique
c'est une piste une autre les charges de
personnel
elle devrait être réduite 30% en trois
ans est l'un des objectifs fixés par la
nouvelle majorité qui a déjà évoqué lors
d'un précédent conseil l'importance de
la mutualisation l'audit sur le
personnel n'est pas encore finalisé
malgré tout michel logis harold est dit
il des situations surprenantes entre le
travail effectué et le nombre de
personnes pour effectuer ce travail
par contre pas question de revoir
l'aménagement du territoire sur toutes
les communes des projets sont lancés ils
seront maintenus et soutenu l'opposition
notamment par la voix de l'élu
socialiste de monts
ni vivien gaasch a regretté jeudi le
manque d'orientation lors de ce débat il
y à quelques axes mais pas de vraies
propositions françois de ligne et le
maire de guyancourt a même estimé que
les conditions du débat n'était pas
remplie et sandrine grand gaube
vice-présidente et et lui attrape s'est
interrogé sur la pertinence de demeurer
dans l'exécutif si at elle expliqué on
découvre tour moment du vote du budget à
ces remarques le président de
l'agglomération a rétorqué que c'était
une situation historiquement compliqué
et qu'il proposerait un conseil des
maires avant le vote un vote prévu le 9
avril
ce soir là on en saura plus sur les
secteurs concernés par les économies à
faire tous les secteurs seront impactés
pas un plus que l'autre a d'ores et déjà
prévenu michel laugier et en politique
la campagne pour l'élection
départementale qui s'accélère les
binômes de candidats sont connus depuis
mardi ils sont 226 dans les yvelines
tour d'horizon ils sont 226 226 à
prétendre à un poste de conseiller
départemental des yvelines l'élection se
déroulera les 22 et 29 mars
chaque électeur de chacun des 21 cantons
votre en réalité pour un binôme hommes
femmes la droite déjà largement
majoritaire entend rester premier parti
des yvelines et a donc sceller son
alliance avec les centristes de l'udf
pendant que la gauche part divisée que
le front national entend jouer les
trouble-fête en se présentant
c'est une première dans toute les
yvelines dans le détail sur le secteur
de saint quentin on retrouve sur le
canton de montigny le bretonneux le
président de l'agglomération michel
laugier divers droite
associé à laurence trochut de l'ump le
sortant socialiste françois de ligne et
maire de guyancourt fait alliance avec
la responsable départementale du ps
sandrine grand gang
un duel qui sera particulièrement suivie
l'absence d'union à gauche avec une
liste europe écologie les verts front de
gauche sera peut-être déterminant la
droite entend réaliser le grand chelem
sur ces élections de l'aveu du président
sortant pierre bédier et pour cela elle
n'hésite pas à envoyer des élus de
premier plan
ainsi jean michel fourgous maire ump
d'elancourt et anne capio sa deuxième
adjointe vont tenter de ravir le canton
de trappes à jeanine marie divers gauche
et alain ajaj mehr communiste de la
verrière qui lui n'a pas reçu le soutien
de son parti qui préfèrent l'alliance
avec europe ecologie les verts
candidature surprise celle du directeur
du collège musulman de saint-quentin
haut niveau
seyman busan à un cas atypique sur le
canton de maurepas ce sont deux
conseillers sortants qui se font face en
raison du redécoupage imposées par
l'état ismaila vannes ps face à yves
vandewalle ump chacun avec son binôme
christine merci adjointe à magny les
hameaux et alexandra rosetti maire de
voisins-le-bretonneux là aussi fortes
divisions à gauche entre l'alliance
écologiste communiste et la présence du
candidat malheureux aux dernières
municipales à maurepas michel chat pas
sûr plaisir à présent division des
écologistes et des communistes présence
du front national présence de debout la
france et rivalités ump ps
pas moins de six listes l'élu
départemental sortant le socialiste jean
michel gourdon a décidé de ne pas se
représenter
enfin sur le canton de saint ciers à
l'école jean philippe mallet brigue un
nouveau mandat avec la socialiste
fabienne james bond bilbo mais après
avoir remporté la mairie de bois d'arcy
l'ump philippe benassaya aimerait
renforcer son implantation sur le
secteur avec l'aide de l'ue dit sonia
bros ces listes de candidats restent
néanmoins provisoire le ministère de
l'intérieur doit encore se prononcer sur
leur validité
dans l'actualité de cette semaine
également la signature du projet contrat
plan état région 2015 2020 mais elle va
le premier ministre et jean paul huchon
président de l'ile-de-france viennent
d'officialiser quelques 7,3 milliards
d'euros d'investissements publics
notamment pour l'enseignement supérieur
la mobilité multimodale ou encore la
transition énergétique 7,3 milliards
d'euros pour les projets de la région
ile de france sur les 6 prochaines
années c'est le montant total du contrat
de plan etat-région signé ce lundi après
midi par le premier ministre manuel
valls et jean paul huchon conseil
régional une somme qui sera
essentiellement investis dans les
transports à hauteur de 5,2 milliards
au programme la modernisation du réseau
de rer le prolongement d'eole vers
mantes la jolie et le bouclage du plan
tramway qu'en réalité on peut dire que
il bat le travail est fini c'est loin
d'être le cas mais on dispose sécurité
absolue en matière d'investissements
transport elsa franchement c'est le
résultat
bien sûr de négociation et même parfois
de bagarre avec gouvernement avec bercy
et ctia mais le premier sera vraiment
carrément
si j'ose dire appuyé sur le sujet à
noter que ce contrat etat-région
concerne aussi l'enseignement supérieur
l'innovation l'emploi la transition
écologique lors du vote du projet de
contrat survenu la semaine dernière ps
et europe ecologie les verts avaient
voté pour le front de gauche et les
centristes de l'udf s'étaient abstenus
le mp avait voté contre
et si vous voulez suivre également
l'actualité politique ce week end vous
avez rendez vous avec l'hebdo politique
de radio sensations nos confrères qui se
sont déplacés au parlement la rencontre
de l'eurodéputée europe ecologie les
verts pascal durand interrogé par un
nicolas kirilow vite il reviendra
notamment sur la culture des ogm en
europe
extraits concrètement même si la
commission européenne autorise la
culture d'une variété les états membres
pourront l'interdire sur leur territoire
ce dossier est vieux et date de presque
5 ans pascal durand est il enfin temps
de trouver une solution et ont clôturé
le débat est il et il est tard clôture
et certainement pas parce que on en vend
beaucoup de choses à dire sur son cas
non parce qu'on a on attendre la
commission on attend de monsieur juncker
qu'il fasse que monsieur barroso n'a pas
fait c'est à dire une réforme très
claire des procédures d'évaluation des
ogm parce que ça c'est un vrai sujet
maintenant ce que ce que vous me dites
et sur le texte qui a été voté la
semaine passée au parlement européen
la la la difficulté là aussi nous avons
c'est une difficulté de principe
c'est à dire que l'europe encore une
fois a failli fait je suis un européen
convaincu et je pense que c'est au
niveau du continent qu'on doit résoudre
les problèmes à chaque fois qu'on
renationalisé une politique on échoue
tout simplement parce que derrière il ya
le marché intérieur la bonne solution ce
serait que au niveau européen on est à
nouveau la capacité d'avoir une agence
et des expertises indépendantes
parce que pour le moment et c'est ça
aussi le grand danger de cette nouvelle
directive
c'est que on donne beaucoup trop de
pouvoir beaucoup trop de pouvoirs aux
entreprises qui fabriquent les ogm
puisque c'est elle qui amènent leurs
propres tests qui amènent leurs propres
études et qui demande la
commercialisation sur la base de leurs
propres
de leurs propres études ça n'est pas
normal ça n'est pas comme ça que ça
devrait se passer
donc ça on attend une réforme de juncker
c'est pour ça que je vous disais tout à
l'heure ça n'est pas ce n'est pas fini
le journal qui se referme juste à un
dernier clin d'oeil à un livre linois
guillaume canet qui est ce vendredi soir
en compétition aux césars dans la
catégorie du meilleur acteur pour son
rôle dans la prochaine fois je viserai
le coeur la concurrence sera rude face à
lui et romain duris pour une nouvelle
amie ou encore françois damiens pour la
famille bélier je vous retrouve en tout
cas lundi on reviendra sur ce résultat
ce sera au même horaire excellent week
end